Mark
32830 watch here this again destroys the
Joe's Witnesses who say the spirit is
God's active
Force why when's the last time you heard
of a person blaspheming an active Force
look at how glorious the holy spirit is
How Majestic the holy spirit is did he
leave I think he I thought he was here
so now I'll just post no he's still here
anyway in Mark 328 to 30 assuredly I say
to you all sins will be forgiven the
sons of men and whatever blasphemies
they may utter but he who blasphemes
against the Holy Spirit never has
forgiveness but is subject to Eternal
condemnation because they said he has an
unclean Spirit now help me
understand what how much sense does it
make to
say you can blaspheme the Holy Spirit if
the holy spirit is not a person but an
energy an active Force and how much
sense does it make to say you can blashe
anyone and be forgiven but if you blashe
the Holy Spirit you cannot be forgiven
when it's only God who deserves such
honor that if you blashe God that should
bring about an unpardonable
sin you he me
there this only makes sense if the holy
spirit is a person who can be slandered
insulted Ed and blasphemed and the fact
that if you slander and insult and
blaspheme him you'll never be forgiven
shows he must be God because this shows
that he has Divine dignity and honor and
Worth to the extent that if you grieve
him you commit a sin against the
greatest conceivable being who possesses
the greatest conceivable dignity and
honor which can only be true of God
right does it make sense saying I just
insulted water I just blasphemed
electricity no that doesn't make sense
this only makes sense the holy spirit is
a person and to say you can blashe
anyone anything and be forgiven but if
you blaspheme the holy spirit that is
unforgivable well the only being who has
that value that worth that can bring
about eternal condemnation is
God
right and let me show you how glorious
the holy spirit is let me show you how
glorious the holy spirit is let's read
the Matan parallel the Ma Matthew's
version of the saying and then I'll
explain how you Blaser because this
often comes up hey Sam how do you
blasing the Holy
Spirit okay Matthew 12
31-32 yeah exactly or Star Wars stole it
from the Joe's Witnesses because the
Joe's Witnesses were around before star
Star Wars Star
Wars nothing but Star
Wars Matthew 12
31-32 watch
here this is the matthean version of the
saying of our Lord watch here guys be in
for a
shock be in for a shock Matthew 12:
31-32 therefore I say to you every sin
and blasphemy will be forgiven men but
blasphemy against the spirit will not be
forgiven men now here's where you should
be shocked anyone who speaks a word
against the son of man Jesus it will be
forgiven him but whoever speaks against
the Holy Spirit it will not be forgiven
him either in this age or in the age to
come what is going on here so you can
speak a word against the son of man
Jesus be forgiven but not against the
Holy Spirit I thought Jesus in a spirit
are equal in Divinity what this does
show you
is what this does show you is that the
spirit is a person like Jesus is a
person just like Jesus can be offended
and blasphemed and slandered against so
the Holy Spirit showing the spirit is a
person like
Jesus you don't speak against
electricity against water against an
inanimate object you don't slander
inanimate objects active forces you only
slander speak against and blasphemy and
insult
persons so just like Jesus is a person
that you can speak out against slander
insult and blasphemy likewise the Holy
Spirit must be a person if you can
blaspheme him slander him insult
him but why is it that if you do blashe
the Holy Spirit you're guilty of an
unforgivable sin but if you blashe Jesus
you can be forgiven
you guys want me to take a moment to
unpack this because if I unpack the meat
of this why does Jesus say if you insult
me you'll be forgiven because the clue
is in the word he used notice the words
of our Lord he didn't say if you speak
out against the Son of God he said if
you speak out against the son of man
you'll be forgiven so let's unpack it
Jesus knew his audience better than his
audience knew themselves he knew they're
looking at a human being son a man in
this context means Jesus as a human the
human Jesus he knew that they're looking
at a human being a flesh and blood Jew
and he knew they'd be offended and
scandalized by this Jew speaking as God
so he knew their natural reaction being
Jews who taught in the Old Testament God
is not a man that they would take
offense at him and think he's a
blasphemer so because of that Jesus is
patient and will
tolerate their sland
because he realizes to them this is a
shock a man claiming to be God so he'll
be patient with them so notice the words
if you speak out against the son of
man because they don't realize he's God
they're seeing a Jew who speaks as if
he's God and according to the Old
Testament God is not a man and a Jew
dare not claim to be God so the Lord in
his Mercy is patient he understands I
know you're being scandalized I know
you're being shocked that a man speaks
as God do you get it now so that's why
I'm patient and will tolerate it up to a
limit but now why does he say if you
speak against the Holy Spirit you won't
be forgiven because it's the Holy Spirit
who is working with Jesus to provide
miraculous Supernatural confirmation
that Jesus is more than a son of man so
that when you now attack the spirit and
grieve the spirit and you reach a point
where the spirit is so insulted he won't
tolerate it you now have cut off your
only hope and chance of realizing the
true identity of Christ because it's the
spirit who's convicting you and trying
to convince you this son of man is more
than a man he's God In the Flesh so when
you insult the only hope you have of
realizing that Jesus is more than a man
then it's over for you because without
the spirit you cannot know who Jesus
truly
is you understand the point of Our
Lord you understand what he's
saying I expect that you'll be
scandalized at me claiming to be God
because all you see is the son of man a
man but now the holy spirit is working
with me and through me giving you
miraculous confirmation I'm more than a
man and now that you're seeing the works
of the spirit the Miracles of the spirit
such as I casting on demons now what you
do is now you insult him and accusing
him of being Satan now you've crossed
the line because without the spirit
convincing you you can never know me
truly and accept me as I am but now
you've insulted him cutting yourself off
from him your only hope of coming to
me you understand and where do we get
that from First Corinthians 12:3 May the
spirit strengthen my throat and my voice
and I speak clearly and accurately
say AVS exactly the spirit must convince
the Muslim but you can resist the spirit
to the point where the spirit is so
griev offended he's done with you
there's only so much the spirit will put
up with then you reach the breaking
point where he's done with you 1
Corinthians
12:3 spirit will put up with then you
reach the breaking point where he's done
with you 1 Corinthians
12:3 without the spirit you cannot know
and confess Jesus as Lord 1 Corinthians
12: verse three exactly lanto so you see
why the Lord said what he said here it
is therefore I want you to understand
that no one speaking in the spirit of
God ever says Jesus is a curse and no
one can say Jesus is Lord except in the
Holy
Spirit see that 1 Corinthians 12:3 here
it is 1 Corinthians 123 and no one can
say Jesus is Lord except in the Holy
Spirit by the Holy Spirit see it that's
why in John 167 to11 Jesus says the
spirit of truth will convict the world
of sin righteousness and
judgment right of sin because they don't
believe in
him of righteousness because I go to the
father and of judgment because the rule
of this world is condemned do you catch
it it's the spirit in John 16:7 to 11
that convict the world you're in sin
because you don't believe in Jesus and
it's a who then convinces the world that
Jesus was not condemned as a blasphemer
god Vindicated him by raising him from
the dead and he's alive and he reigns
from heav and as Lord so without this
Spirit you won't be convinced that Jesus
is the son of God who's alive without
the spirit you won't be convinced you're
sinner that needs to turn to him without
the spirit you cannot confess Jesus as
Lord and remain faithful to him you see
how important the holy spirit is
you hear me
there so you see why Jesus says I will
tolerate blasphemies against the son of
man me because I expect you'll be
scandalized that a flesh and blood Jew
speaks as God but when I show up in the
power of the Holy Spirit and I'm doing
Miracles by the spirit such as
destroying the kingdom of darkness
casting out demons and then you turn
around and then insult that Holy Spirit
and say he's Satan you've now crossed
the line you've now committed a
blasphemy against the spirit you now
grieved him he's done with
you and if he's done with you it's over
you have no hope of ever turning to
Christ you're done with it's over and
out because that's the sin they're
committing in Mark 3 and Matthew 12 what
is the sin if you read Mark 322 down and
Matthew 12:22 onward
Jesus is casting out demons and they say
ah it's by
B the ruler of demons he cast out demons
calling the Holy Spirit Satan that Satan
was filling Jesus God forbid such
blasphemy to cast out demons and Jesus
said it's over for you that's it it's
done by now calling him Satan you have
soul grieve the spirit he's done with
you and convicting you and drawing you
to Christ
and this is a warning to people today if
you do not submit to the spirit if you
have not turned to Christ and the spirit
keeps convicting you and convincing you
Jesus is Lord you're in sin you need to
turn to him but you keep resisting and
refusing to submit and keep justifying
your sin then you can reach a point
where the spirit says I'm done with you
now you have blasphemed the spirit and
it's over but when you reach that point
you don't care anymore let me tell you
how you know someone's reached that
point he could care less about Jesus he
could care less about the spirit he
could care less about the Bible he could
care less about the things of God but he
Revels and delights in his Wicked
lifestyle and justifies it that person
has reached the point of blasing the
spirit he's now reached the point of
reprobation the spirit hands him over